[Music]
all right let's go to um
andrew in little rock arkansas what's up
andrew
hey dr john thanks for having me on you
bet man thanks for coming on and hanging
out with us for a little while what's up
dude
hey well i
am about a year out removed from a
pretty tough divorce and i feel like
i've done
most of the things right but i'm still
dealing with some issues and then also i
feel like i've almost developed
like a
almost an anxiety tick that i seemingly
can't break even though almost a year
has passed
and i'm not sure what to go what to do
or what to go from
and so i've poured myself into my you
know my friends and my work and
my family outside of my divorce and
all of that has gone really well
but
over the past year even though there's
no evidence to suggest that i'm dealing
with this problem i've become incredibly
anxious
about just being insecure and losing my
hair even though baldness doesn't even
run in my family
and i'm
i'm not balding but i still worry about
it almost all the time and i don't know
if that's just because of
i've done almost everything else quote
unquote right recovering from the
divorce and my body is just trying to
find something to worry about there you
go dude
yeah you're getting that's awesome i'm
glad you're i'm glad you figured that
out that's awesome
um so
how long were y'all married
we were married just under two years
what happened
uh unfortunately she had pretty much
lived
a double life our entire relationship
and she had been cheating on me pretty
much the whole time
it's very common for people to say like
oh my ex was crazy but when i was
reading about it more later
i learned about narcissistic personality
disorder
and it seemed like she really fit the
bill for that
so she just she never apologized there
was never any closure
and she cut literally everyone off right
away and
it was over in a weekend
and so were you um
did you have any idea or were you all in
i was all in um i
in the last few months of our marriage i
thought something was wrong
but we were also in the last year of
college and we're just both in our
senior projects and just trying to
survive and so
i kind of chalked everything up
to that
um looking back there were some things
that it's like oh yeah now that that
makes sense but there was no like moment
where you know friends come up and like
i wish i had told you or like had seen
other things like no one
even her own like
her own maid of honor had no idea and
isn't friends with her anymore and is
still friends with me
type deception okay and so
um
yeah
oh man
there's a lot of avenues to take here
um before your marriage you struggle
with anxiety in the past
yeah you know i i've always yeah i've
definitely been a worrier um
you know and it's always it's rotated
seemingly kind of through things in life
but i guess now with the problem that
i'm dealing with now is that
it's like an everyday thing even
uh like there was one caller on the show
uh a few weeks ago that i'd heard where
you had made a joke about how like you
weren't expecting to be married to a guy
that didn't have this much hair or like
as much hair on his head and that like
sent me
into thinking about it at work when i
hadn't i was like ah shoot and it's just
stuff like that like
i've handed comments that'll have
nothing to do with it will now kick me
and it all started too from
a joke that someone made about my hair
and literally ever since then i've just
been and okay so
let me walk you through because
you're sounding like uh you're sounding
like me
so that one little seemingly innocent
comment
um
you get that warm feeling in your
stomach
you know what i mean like you're cut and
then your heart starts beating a little
bit faster
and now you're then you start getting
amped up like no it's fine it's fine
it's fine
and that seems to put gasoline on it and
then your body's off to the races man
yeah like my heart will my heart rate
will go up while i'm at work at a desk
and you know yeah okay so hear me say
this clearly and i know you know this
this has zero nothing to do with your
hair
has zero nothing to do with your body
has zero nothing to do with any of these
external things
okay
this is a body that's trying to get your
attention in any way that it can
so when you were worried that's marriage
is a thing and we'll get back to your
marriage
who taught you to worry
uh
i would say both of my parents kind of
worry in their own ways okay um
i don't think they i think they did
their best
don't defend them they're grown-ups
they're tough they're fine
i think i think they they never pushed
it on me but i could see their anxiety
and that's just how i learned to do it
okay so parents don't often push things
on their kids kids absorb tension in a
household
and kids kids absorb that disconnection
between mom and dad right
and kids try to solve that
and the body knows we're not connected
and when mom and dad is off in their own
world trying to solve their own issues
and yes they're feeding and watering the
kids but that's part of it kids need to
be anchored into mom and dad and when
they're not anchored in
they
spin spin and spin and spin and spin
making perfect grades getting straight
hundreds can often be an anxiety
response it can be a way to try to quell
that to try to clear jump that that gulf
between mom and dad back right
and
rumination is another fun one it may be
that more than anxiety
it sounds very ocd is what you're
struggling with and i'm not going to
diagnose you so
i'm not giving you a diagnostic i'm
saying this is the loop right the
loop-de-loop d-loop-d-loop but instead
of checking locks in your house your
brain is ticking off okay what about
this what about this what about this
what about this oh there it is there it
is there it is they're not gonna love us
we're gonna be stuck by us right and
then now it's now
now i'm in full fledge fight or flight
and i gotta ride this sucker out right
and it's exhausting way to live
my guess is
you have done a remarkable job
of
of
running down the checklist
but you have not fully grieved the two
big things that happen when somebody
cheats on you
you haven't fully grieved that somebody
looked at you and decided i want
somebody else
which is devastating
and you haven't grieved the secret evil
of divorce which is
you missed it
and now
it was confirmed that andrew is not
trustworthy
because i'm i couldn't even tell with my
wife
and your body's trying to get your
attention that we're not okay we're not
safe we're not in control we're
disconnected and so you've hung out with
people and you've gotten busy at work
did you go back to the gym
i did yeah cool you went back to school
you
um have you like started reading some
books
yeah i've read books started doing
jiu-jitsu
awesome
those things that you're doing are
fantastic but here's what they do they
provide an extraordinary strong anchored
foundation
for you to do the really hard crap
yeah and that's what you haven't done
and so your body feels busy
and it feels full
and your brain is screaming at you we're
still not safe
because those external things were never
the problem
yeah is that fair
yeah i guess my my only thing or not my
own thing but my my question to that
would be
i feel like
i felt obviously you know everyone goes
through it differently but i felt like i
went through all of
the
quote unquote stages of grief
throughout the year
and i guess
i don't know i guess i don't know how
else to continue to grieve and deal with
it because i feel like
like the problem like you were
mentioning with ruminations it's like
what's the difference between dealing
with it and grieving versus ruminating
and just sitting and dwelling on those
thoughts the difference the difference
yes absolutely it's a great question
ruminating is when your mind spins out
and it feels like productive thinking it
feels like it's trying to help you
and it's not it's an activity it's and
your brain gets addicted to that by the
way because it spins up the stress
chemicals and your body gets addicted to
the stress chemicals and if you're doing
all these other things like jiu jitsu
and exercise and whatever
then you're not giving the body it's hit
that it needs
so basically your head is is a crack
dealer now and it knows how to get its
hit if you're not gonna get it in the
real world we're gonna spin up some
thoughts and get it that way
and then your body launches into a fight
or flight that you're not even
have you had the moment when you're like
there's nothing wrong here there's
nobody coming at me with a hatchet
there's no out of control barber gonna
take off the rest of my hair but your
body's acting as though somebody's
chasing you with the clippers right
yeah
i've i've had that moment where i now
i've i've you know i dealt i told my my
family some of my worries and like i
showed them pictures from years ago
where my hairline is exactly the same as
it is now
and now they give me a hard time about
worrying about it
right right it's not they they joke
about it because it's not happening
right but this isn't about your hair
yeah this is about a mind trying to get
its body's attention
and so here's a couple of things that
you didn't mention
are you sleeping
uh
i initially it's kind of gone through
waves okay initially it was not great
and then i really locked it down
more recently i was super
super blessed i actually closed on a
house
and have been in the process of moving
and that has definitely affected my
sleep
but how much money do you owe
how much money do i owe yeah
how in debt free outside of my house
okay great
you feel good about this house
yeah yeah no it's i think it's a it's
way more than enough space for me and
it's i think it'll be a good investment
okay for the future
um i
yeah that that that's the other thing
too like i used to when i was married i
was worried about money more often than
not
but now that i've been single and have
been doing doing things pretty well in
that regard like my body i'm not worried
about it and so i feel like that's also
partially why i've moved on to something
else okay so here's a couple of things i
want you to practice okay
the first thing is is when your body
spins up i want you to be curious about
it don't get don't don't give in to the
panic
what i mean by that is when it somebody
mentions
um something about losing your hair
and you spin up
ask yourself in that moment what are
what around me is not safe
what in my environment is not safe did i
sleep last night am i not calling my
friends did i skip a thing like i want
to figure out what my body's really
responding to because it's not this
because my hair is fine
i know that cognitively
something in my defaults wiring system
is trying to protect me from something
what is it
what is it
and usually it's one of three things i'm
not connected i don't have um
i don't have a connection i'm sorry i'm
not connected i'm not safe or i'm not in
control i don't have autonomy and it
sounds like you're working towards all
three of those things in a really
remarkable way
here's another truth that people don't
like to hear and people have jumped on
to
yeah delony hates medication whatever
i think we're way over medicated and
if you've worked with a faulty alarm
system for a long time
there is a season when medication can
really help reset that thing
okay
and it might be worth sitting with a
doctor saying here's all the things i'm
doing and my anxiety alarms are still
still ringing
the catch is if you start taking meds
you have to go see a counselor too have
you done that
i
uh
i have not and i should i i should have
however i guess my only i became a
little bit jaded with it because i had
been going to counseling before the
divorce
trying to improve myself and then kind
of
afterwards when i realized it's not that
i mean i wasn't a perfect spouse no one
is but you know i never broke our vows
andrew uh andrew yeah your divorce
wasn't your fault
you didn't do anything wrong
here hold on
you did not do anything wrong
okay
yeah and you're trying to solve the the
algorithm
and there's no there's not going to be a
solution the computer is going to run
and run and run and run until smoke
comes out of the out of the machine
you got hurt yeah and somebody screwed
you over
probably somebody that's not well
and quite honestly it doesn't matter
because it hurt
yeah
and you deserved better than that you
didn't get it
that's the exhale
that feeling you're feeling right this
second that's grief
that's the yeah dude i didn't do
anything
and getting a bunch of getting great abs
becoming good at fighting all those
things are fun and good
getting a lot of books getting a new
house getting a new job all those things
are great
they have zero to do with the divorce
yeah the divorce is because something
was not well with her
not you
and anxiety rings when we find ourselves
in situations that we can't control it
and one of the most damning scary things
is we can't control other people
i can't can i
can't make her stay
and then the alarms sound
given all the work you've done my
brother i think it's time you write her
a letter don't send it
let her know how you really feel
you may not have done that
go see a doctor and then you have to see
a counselor too combine both of them
okay
here's the good news you're doing hard
hard work and you love yourself which is
beautiful and you understand that you're
worth doing this work and that's great
and let me tell you on the other side of
what you're feeling right now there is
wellness there is healing there is sleep
there is a deep deep laughter i promise
you that
but you have to walk through the
darkness and so you to get some people
that will walk through it with you